avec nous euh on va parler d'une vidéo
virale c'est une catastrophe invité du
soir on va on va parler d'une vidéo très
difficile qui fait le tour des réseaux
sociaux faut vraiment que toutes les
familles regardent cette séquence parce
que vous allez voir ça va vous parler
vous allez vous dire c'est inadmissible
et on ne veut vraiment plus que ça
arrive il s'agit de l'agression encore
filmée ce qui filme à chaque fois ses
abrutis heureusement d'ailleurs qu'ils
sont abrutis pour filmer VO quoi
heureusement ils sont tellement brutis
une adolescente de 15 ans qui a eu lieu
le 25 janvier dernier au lycée Rosa par
à monongeron ce soir elle est venue
accompagné de de Stéphanie sa maman pour
témoigner dans TPMP on va en parler avec
Amor buucco au journaliste police
justice qui a toutes les dernières infos
sur ce drame on va regarder la vidéo de
l'agression attention regardez ces
images sont violentes bien entendu mais
c'est important de voir ce qui se passe
parce que c'est pas un cas isolé
regardez 20h58 on est en direct amis
bucot merci d'être là journaliste police
justice et merci à Stéphanie euh
la maman de la victime et la victime qui
est avec nous qu'on appellera mais
ou voilà nom d'emprun c'est un nom
d'emprunt c'est le nom qu'elle a choisi
voilà victime de l'agression amori
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé déjà pour
noter les spectateurs il est 20h58 dit
alors la scène que vous venez de voir ça
s'est passé jeudi dernier le 25 janvier
dans le lycée Rosa Parks à dans dans
lesson à mongeron et et bien ce qui
s'est passé c'est que mais a 15 ans elle
est devant moi elle sort de son cours
d'histoire géographie ce jour-là il est
aux alentours de de 14h et elle constate
et bien un attroupement de lycéenes mais
aussi de quelques lycéens devant sa
salle de classe dont certains ont déjà
sorti leur téléphone portable pour
filmer quelque chose alors maice elle ne
sait pas ce que c'est et puis elle ne
s'attarde pas spécialement parce qu'elle
a un cours d'espagnol dans une autre
salle de classe et donc elle doit aller
à ce cours d'espagnol alors à ce
moment-là il y a une élève de ce de ce
groupe qui lui attrape la Manche et qui
lu dit viens faut qu' qu'on parle et
donc qu' emmène à l'écart dans un coin
et c'est là que les violences commencent
voilà he ce que raconte mais dans son
procèsverbal de plainre que j'ai j'ai pu
consulter elle prend ma tête par les
cheveux et la cogne trois fois contre la
fenêtre donc au débure dans un premier
temps c'est ce qu'on voit d'ailleurs
mais se défend le temps de se défendre
mais rapidement bien il y a une deuxième
élève qui arrive pour frapper mais et
finalement et bien mais tombe par terre
elle est rouée de coup quand elle est
par terre et elle perd connaissance il
faut bien avoir consciance que tout ça
se passe devant des rires des
exclamations de nombreux lycéens qui
sont en train de filmer la scène alors
malheureusement on voit pas la fin de la
scène mais donc comme je vous le disais
mais per connaissance c'est elle reprend
connaissance quelques minutes plus tard
un professeur vient l'extirper du groupe
mais en fait elle prend du temps à
reprendre connaissance parce que
finalement elle a perdu la mémoire elle
sait plus trop qui elle est ni sa salle
de classe elle est emmenée à
l'infirmerie et c'est à l'infirmerie
qu'on prévient son père qu' l'emmène aux
urgences puisque on voit qu'elle est
vraiment pas bien aux urgences on lui
fait un scanner du cerveau et on
constate que heureusement il n'y a pas
de dégâts cérébraux euh mais évidemment
elle est extrêmement marquée sur le plan
à la fois physique et psychique on l'a
quand même il y a eu un examen médical
elle a quand même 15 jours d'ITT 15
jours d'incapacité totale de travail ce
qui est quand même assez énorme et bien
sûr bien elle elle ne veut plus
retourner à l'école depuis faut quand
même comprendre que depuis bah
évidemment les images ont énormément
tourn dans son école comme souvent dans
les cas de harcèlement malheureusement
la police a ouvert une enquête hein
c'est ce que nous a confir
le parquet ce matin et la principale
élève mise en cause qu'on voit
d'ailleurs dans ces images en train de
frapper maice a été exclu de de
l'établissement temporairement le temps
qu'il y ait un conseil de discipline
c'est ce que nous a indiqué l'académ de
versa n'importe quoi comme
d'habitude mais on ne sait pas pour les
autres filles qui ont frappé myis on ne
sait pas ce qu'il en est aujourd'hui
merci en tout cas Stéphanie la maman de
ma d'être avec nous merci ma d'être là
ma déjà comment tu te sens aujourd'hui
bah je suis toujours sous le choc de ce
qui s'est passé parce que je trouve que
c'est injuste que certaines personnes
qui m'ont fait ça sont encore à l'école
et moi je dois rester chez moi
euh
je je me sens encore pas bien j'ai
encore des bleus j'ai encore mal un peu
partout sur le corps et je trouve que ça
va très très mais très lentement
et j'aimerais juste que ça ça se
reproduise pour personne d'autre en fait
j'ai envie que ce qui s'est passé
personne d'autre le vive parce que c'est
horrible en fait au quotidien par peux
nous raconter ce qui s'est passé maïs
parce que pourquoi il y a eu cette cette
Rix raconte-nous c'est quoi la la c'est
quoi le le c'est qui qui a mis le feu au
poudre qu'est-ce qui s'est passé bah en
fait les personnes je les connaissais
pas et apparemment il y a 6 mois je les
avais filmé en train de se battre
donc ils ont voulu régler ça aujourd'hui
tu les Avaz filmé en train de se battre
et donc ça quoi ça leur avait pas plu
euh oui donc qu'est-ce qu'elle t'avait
dit il y avait eu un truc sur les
réseaux il y a eu quoi il y a eu des non
c'est des rumeurs des rumeurs et donc
quoi et tu savais qu'elle t'attendait ou
pas du tout c'était quoi c'était un
gétapant qu'est-ce qui s'est passé je
savais pas qu' était devant ma salle
parce que justement je m' je j'allais en
cours d'espagnol donc je savais pas
qu'elle av dans ma salle selon moi c'est
un acte qui a été prémédité d'accord
donc il y a sûrement un élève de sa
classe qui a donné son emploi du temps
parce que les les filles sont arrivées
au moment où elles sortait de sa salle
de cours euh donc elles se sont jetées
violemment sur elle l'ont ramené dans un
coin pour commencer à la tabasser et
c'est inadmissible ce qui s'est passé
c'était combien au moins une dizaine
hein une dizaine donc elles te disent
quoi quand elles viennent pour te
tabasser c'est ça comment ça se passe
elles me disent qu'on doit parler
d'accord et après elle me demande si je
les ai traité de [__] et elle
commence à c'est quoi si je les ai
traité de [__] si vous voulez tu les
avais traité de [__] oui oui c'est
quoi cette affaire parce que tu les
avais traité il y avait un truc ou pas
du tout tu les connaissis mê pas non pas
du tout en fait pensais que j'avais
j'avais montré la vidéo que je j'avais
apparemment filmé à des garçons en
disant que je les avaent traité de
[__] non c'est c'est c'est c'est
quoi ça donc en fait elle a eu voilà es
se sont jeté sur elle à
plusieurs parce qu'elle aurait
soi-disant traité cette jeune fille du
coup qui est l'auteur hein de de de
cette agression de de conasse donc
plutôt que je lui demandé des
explications elle lui a tapé dessus
voilà et aujourd'hui c'est la seule qui
a été donc euh mis à l'écart de donc de
l'établissement et pendant ce temps ben
les autres qui sont aussi présentes qui
filment qui rigole que ça amuse sont
donc à l'école tranquillement pendant
qu'Océane ben elle elle
c'est incroyable si vous nous rejoignez
à 21h4 c'est d'une violence extrême tu
es à l'école en quelle classe seconde
seconde d'accord tout se passe bien pour
toi à l'école oui tout pass bien tu as
plein de potes tout va bien tu es et je
tiens quand même à rajouter que ma fille
je la dépose à l'école le matin avant
d'aller travailler je la récupère après
même quand j'arrive en retard je lui dis
tu m'attends dans le lycée et tu sors
euh et quand je vois que ça s'est fait
ça s'est produit au sein de
l'établissement ça je me dis mais on on
est où non mais c'est ça du coup moi
j'ai j'ai plus confiance bien sûr je je
sais pas tous les gens qui nous
regardent à 21h6 en direct doivent se
dire on ils ont plus confiance non plus
donc dans ton
établissement il y a il y a personne qui
a qui savaiit qu'il y a personne qui qui
a alerté quelqu'un personne non B
visiblement non les surveillants se
demande ben où ils était à ce moment-là
bien sûr voilà à quoi ils servent du
coup pour elles sont et et donc toutes
ces jeunes filles sont dans le même dans
le même lycée dans le même lycée elles
sont pas dans la même classe bien mais
elles sont dans le même lycée elles y
sont elles y sont toujours et elles y
sont toujours sauf celles qui portent
les coups à Océane elle a été exclue
mais elle doit passer en conseil de
discipline donc avant les prochaines
vacances conseil de discipline et après
du côté police qui va se passer quand
même probablement faut le dire oui
l'avantage c'est comme il y a les images
et que le le lycée a les noms des des
des jeunes filles ils vont les
transmettre à la police et ce qu'il faut
espérer c'est qu'il y ait rapidement des
gardes à vue et que les filles qui ont
fait ça déjà une garde à vue quand même
ça impressionne et qu'ell soit qu'on les
qu'on les entende qu'on les interroge et
que la justice des mineurs fasse
rapidement le job h làas la justice des
mineurs en général c'est très long c'est
ça le problème euh mais toi aujourd'hui
tu es tu es tu as peur de retourner à
l'école forcément
euh oui j'ai peur j'ai peur parce que je
me dis que ils ont pas tous été
sanctionnés donc je vais sûrement
recroiser recroiser certaines personnes
et que comme je les ai pas tous
identifiés ça peut se reproduire pour
une vengeance ou autre tu as cru que tu
allais mourir à ce moment-là je me
demandais quand ça allait s'arrêter donc
que
oui je me disais je que à tout moment
pouvait sortir quelque chose de
leur quoi tu étais quand même
inconsciente oui ce que vous racontez je
je me permets maice c'est quand même ce
qui est assez frappant dans votre votre
plainte c'est que finalement vous tombez
par terre et là vous vous vous avez
encore les yeux ouverts et vous voyez
qu'on continue à vous frapper vous voyez
des des pieds qui continuent à vous
frapper sur tout le corps ça c'est quand
même assez terrible avant de perdre
connaissance quoi c'est c'est bien ça
oui c'est c'est injuste ce qu'elle a
subi moi j'aimerais vraiment que les
parents prennent leur responsabilité qui
deviennent vraiment mes acteur de
l'éducation de leur enfant justement
est-ce qu'il y a un des parents qui vous
a appelé ou qui vous a contacté pas du
tout rien personne non personne non et
il a fallu que je me déplace dans le
lycée que j'exige un rendez-vous pour
savoir ce qu'il en était s'il y avait
des mesures qui avaient été prise et
j'avais plutôt l'impression de plutôt
les déranger voilà et donc aujourd'hui
ce sentiment que j'ai
aujourd'hui pour revenir à l'affaire
donc toi tu sors tranquillement de
l'école et il y a quelqu'un qui te enfin
pendant l'école qui vient te chercher
qui dit on a te parler elle sort même
pas de l'école sort même pas ou elle est
dans l'école qu elle sort de classe
ouais elle sort de classe il y a
quelqu'un qui vient te
vient l'agresser tu étais pas du tout au
courant pas du tout non parce que si je
savais ouais j'allais prévenir le prof
justement j'allais lui dire monsieur il
y a quelque chose qui se prépare dites
l'heure de partir ou faites quelque
chose donc non je savis pas en fait
c'est pour ça que je parle de
préméditation ouais ça a été organisé
c'est un guetapan ils ont ils savaient
dans dans quelle salle qu'elle était et
elles sont venu l'agresser donc elles
doivent être tout simplement sanctionné
mais sévèrement non mais très sévèrement
ça doit être à titre
d'exemple maisis donc toi quand tu quand
tu la vois arrivé tu tu tuimagines pas
que ça allait être un tel déferlement de
violence derrière comment tu crois tu
t'imagines pas ce qui va se passer
derrière quand elle viens parler parce
que quand elle est arrivée je commence à
descendre les escaliers ou parce que je
savais pas que c'était pour moi d'accord
et je voyais qu'il filmait mais je
calculais vraiment pas parce que pour
moi j'avais de problème avec personne
donc je savais pas que c'était pour moi
je m'apprête à descendre les escaliers
et je sens sa main sur mon manteau que
du coup je refuse de porter mais que
j'ai porté
aujourd'hui d'accord et je vois que tu
essayie de te défendre aussi he oui oui
bien sûr bah oui ouais et et c'est là
que les autres ou c'est ça parce qu'en
fait comme elle voit que défend et que
tu tu elle a des difficulté avec toi ils
viennent tous derrière pour pour l'aider
quoi en fait et ce qui est quand même
choquant c'est que la plupart ben elle
elle filme ça rigole c'est très amusant
ce qui se passe non c'est loin d'être
amusant smile ouais non smile qui se Mar
et tout c'est vraiment des abrutis fin
et et et tes copains et tes copines du
lycée elles t'ont dit quoi
ell quand elles t'ont vu partir c'est ça
le truc tu étais toute seul quand tu as
descendu des escaliers tu avais pas de
potes avec toi j'étais avec de deux amis
de classe à moi ouais et et on c'était
en intercours donc on s'apprêtait à
descendre les escaliers et
elle comprenait pas elles m'ont dit mais
tu as fait quoi pourquoi il y a des
personnes devant enfin c'est qui ouais
ensuite bah elle regardait en fait elle
regard elle me regardait parce que elles
m'ont dit qu'ell pouvait rien faire vu
qu'il y avait plusieurs personnes elles
sont pas essayé d'alerter les
surveillants
non non non elles étaient quoies ont
elles étaient en train de regarder en
fait elles étaient quoi elles étaient là
toute la scène pendant toute la scène
oui voilà
je je sais pas je pensais vraiment pas à
ça à ce moment-là en fait moi j'ai une
de de vos amis au téléphone justement
cet après-midi qui m'a dit que ça avait
durer à peu près 5 minutes ouais et elle
j'ai essayé de lui parler demandé de me
raconter ce qui s'était passé et cetera
mais je sentais qu'elle était très
fermée enfin on sent qu'elle est hyper
gênée par cette histoire aussi que
peut-être qu'elle s'en veut aussi de pas
être intervenue je ne sais pas vous AZ
essayé d'aelle aussi encore àécole vous
avvez essayé d'appeler l'tablissement
oui mais l'établissement de toute façon
dans ces cas-là dans toutes ces affaires
les établissements il se verrou disent
nous on peut pas communiquer
leoratorat qui m'a répondu Gill le le
l'établissement euh rien du tout il a
fallu attendre que vous portiez plainte
pour que le directeur consente à vous
parler si j'ai bien lu c'est ça qu'au
début il y avait aucune prise de
conscience et comme vous êtes au
commissariat là il consent enfin à vous
parler et c'est surtout quand je me suis
rendu et que j'ai exigé d'avoir un
rendez-vous euh qu'ils ont compris et
quand j'ai montré les vidéos c'est là où
ils ont pris du coup ben l'ampleur que
que de de de la situation donc s'il y
avait pas eu de vidéo finalement sûr ils
auraient pas pris en
considération ce qui s'est passé et
c'est juste Stéphanie votre votre mari
il a il a réagi quand parce que c'est
vrai que lui il doit être comme un fou
aussi et bien écoutez on essaie de
garder not oui il faut pour elle bravo à
vous bravo à vous il faut parce que elle
a besoin aussi de se reconstruire et par
rapport à ce qui s'est passé parce que
votre mari au début il a dit dit quoi
elle a dit je je vais je vais tout je
vais tout casser mais moi j'ai dit
pareil hein ouais ça ouais ah oui oui
mais après quand j'ai vu dans l'état
qu'elle était je pouvais pas me
permettre de de de de
de de pleurer voilà je me suis mise en
tu avz pensé à appeler les parents ou
pas du tout
de pas forcément pas forcément je voilà
moi c'était de porter plainte de prendre
contact avec l'établissement et surtout
de médiatiser ce qui s'était passé alors
je vais vous dire là
voyez ou pas typiquement Stéphanie et
son mari de Médiatis ils ont fait tout
comme il fallait et ben on va voir ce
qui va se passerils ont fait tout comme
il fallait
aujourd'hui les agresseurs ils sont à
l'école elle elle est pas à l'école on
va voir ce qui va se passer parce que
vous avez tout fait bien ou que je suis
pas sûr qu'on aurait tous fait comme
vous ici bravo à vous mais c'est vrai
que voilà vous avez tout fait bien vous
avez êtes incroyable vous avez un sang
frroid incroyable vraiment bravo à vous
bravo à votre mari et et on va on la
soutient à fond mais on va vraiment
suivre cette affaire parce qu'on va voir
ce qui va se passer oui parce que
j'espère qu'on va pas avoir de mauvaise
surprise voilà je voudrais vous
remercier d'avoir été avec nous ce soir
et my est-ce que tu as un dernier truc à
dire
euh j'ai juste à dire
que faut faire vraiment très attention à
qui on fait confiance
et aux rumeurs faut pas croire à tout ce
qu'on ce qu'on dit et surtout euh de
jamais lever la main sur une personne si
on n pas de preuve sur ce qu'elle a dit
ou même si on a des preuves c'est jamais
régler régler ce qu'on ce qu'on veut
régler par la force merci bah bravo euh
bravo merci d'avoir été avec N merci
Stéphanie merci on va suivre l'affaire
merci beaucoup d'avoir été avec N bravo